howdy howdy howdy welcome back to M Cube
Today is Wednesday you know Cinema scoop
Wednesday and we have a very special
guest friend of mine Greg crafts over
here real quick Jamie you know you can
mirror these things I just I'm pointing
the right direction now I'm so happy I'm
so happy this has taken us like a year
and a half to figure out no you still
pointing the other direction Bud really
yeah it's just fine on mine
[Music]
the zoom orientation struggle is real so
real yeah stream yards just introduced a
little mirror thing and I was like I'm
so happy I can actually do it
all good
I did that
yeah
it doesn't mirror your picture I did
that and I was going I am pointing the
right way I might have to keep going no
you're not
that happened I I Now understand what
what happened there
but yeah so we have a special friend of
mine uh Greg he's a sag after actor who
just went to San Diego Comic-Con so we
can talk a little bit about Comic Con
and things of the sort talk about the
Striking because you've been on the
picket lines yourself already yeah I've
been on the picket line a few times yeah
so I got to get out there more beautiful
uh
and we just got a couple other questions
and things like that and we do have a
few little tidbits of news we're going
to not try to dive too far into them but
we have a little bit of news so we'll do
that but Jamie
uh we're also on side track this evening
because we want to push people over to
the now I'm doing it
to the M3 Channel Harris you you know
you're doing four or five lives a week
every all you move your news so guys yep
go if you haven't already go and
subscribe to uh
yes and before we roll that intro uh
Greg you said you're not always on but
when you want to talk about yourself
this is the time to not be humble at all
and give people all the goodness all
right well morning everybody my name is
Gregory crafts and I'm a professional uh
actor producer playwright uh lighting
designer I do a little bit of everything
I've been working in uh out in Los
Angeles for about 20 years now be 20
years in August as a matter of fact so
almost almost my 20 year anniversary
here uh I own a cup own and operate a
couple of small theatrical venues in
Hollywood uh as my day job but the
primary hustle I'm I'm pursuing right
now is that I am pursuing one hour
dramas in Hollywood uh I took a very
very long detour through the Los Angeles
theater scene where I uh you know cut my
teeth as a performer and uh as
playwright and learned how to produce
theater and um
yeah I have uh I've
I mean damn I suck at the self-promotion
stuff I do I do a little bit of
everything uh I love I love everything I
do and uh uh I
spent uh like I said I did a long time
going through uh working in the theater
scene and building that all that stuff
up and decided in about 2019 that I was
like you know what I've been out here so
long I really want to get back and try
and get work on screen again so I was
like 2019 I started doing a lot of ramp
up getting representation doing work I
was like 2020 is going to be my year
and I was like you know
it was going to be a year yeah so I come
out of that we get out of that it's
2022. I'm like got better reps God you
know got got new headshots did the whole
thing 2023 is going to be my year you
know and I think I think the universe is
telling me that I just need to stop for
the sake of all of Hollywood I just need
to stop trying to get on TV I think
that's that's for sure so yeah
you know timing kind of happens at its
own pace I I got faith in you because
you are a jack of all trades and where
most people say that and finish it off
with master of none you're a master of a
good portion if not most of them so I'd
like to think I put my 10 000 hours in
in a bunch of different things so yeah I
almost mentioned it but we were talking
right before the stream but like Jamie I
I we would walk in well like I'm
producing a play or last year Well we
did a play together and I technically
produced that one as well but walk in
he's literally got 12 to like 20 other
plays going on in his place that he has
to focus on half the time he's running
lights if it's not him it's his wife or
someone else that is coming on and
usually is is decent with lights but in
our show particularly and I think a
couple other shows this year
they weren't as great which means Greg
had to come in and do it all himself
later and did it
perfectly as always
jack of all trades and master of most
you know
with all that being said though shall We
Roll the intro
let's do it
I if I had some nickel plated
pearl-handed six shooters right now I
would be I'd be very happy I don't think
those are illegal in California though
so
sorry uh how's the world coming to you
either you can't have
you know
the texting in me has one answer for in
the The Challenge version of me has a
different answer for it yeah
but hello to everyone uh David's in here
uh sci-fi Quest Laura's in here uh I
think we got a good evening which means
we've got more Brits over here you know
I love it uh but also
have you seen Stargate Greg
oh my God I have not seen Stargate in a
very very long time
um I watched a little bit of his as a
kid and no I don't think I could do a
ball voice unfortunately
you could come in there and play ball
too
you know some clone that's come in after
the fact or something dude I'm I'm down
for whatever at this point like I I I've
been uh I'm I'm starting to go around to
like the the effect shops and stuff like
that and be like hey you need to just
you know slap 50 pounds of rubber and
Prosthetics on somebody for for a role
sure like let's go you know Greg Jones
like right
I've met Doug I'm I used to in my
previous life uh my previous corporate
life before
um my wife and I bought our theaters uh
I worked for a toy company a
Collectibles company and uh Doug uh well
we we did a lot of Collectibles for
Gamera Del Toro and Doug was in there
all the time with us we also did full
body digital scanning and stuff like
that and we had a division that was full
body digital scanning and digital assets
for films for post-production and then
we would take those scans and do product
development with them we'd do action
figures Collectibles things like that
and I worked in the Collectibles
Division and
um Doug would come by our booth a
Comic-Con all the time
oh he'd come into the studio and get
scanned and do all the other stuff but
then he'd come and be at the booth the
Comic-Con and at one point I'm sitting
in the back of our booth with Doug and
Guillermo del Toro just talking about
acting and I was just like what is this
life and then I realized that they're
like oh they see me as the sales guy for
this toy company like that's oh God that
was rough uh but Doug gives great hugs
he is a legendary hugger and he gives
wonderful hugs he is a wonderfully
wonderful man love him to death he's got
the perfect length for it you know yeah
oh yeah I would think Guillermo del Toro
probably gives a damn good hug too I
think so I did not have the I did not
have the pleasure
yeah he's got to have a teddy bear
it might have like a scary monster pop
out behind his back as he hugs you but
it'll still be very easy
Doug Jones will pop out behind Guillermo
del Toro as Ian was hugging you well and
that's the thing is that it's it's uh
Ron Perlman too Ron Perlman will just
show up wherever Gilmore is and just and
just be there like we were here was
doing a signing we go out front and
suddenly like I'm I'm working the
security line like keeping everybody in
line to come this this was my life at
Comic-Con before I went started going as
a professional actor trying to do all
the networking stuff working at this
booth and I swear to God we're doing the
signing for um
oh my God what's
why am I blanking on the name of this
film it's the it's it's Pan the Fawn
Pan's Labyrinth pants yeah yeah he we
did some minibus for Pan's Labyrinth
think you're almost signing them and uh
and it's just Guillermo at the table and
and I turn around and I turn back around
like two seconds later Ron perlman's
just sitting there with him just
shooting the [__] and smoking a cigar
like on the con floor like like what
what is this you know and he just
appeared out of nowhere but it was like
the most natural thing for him he's just
he just showed up sat down and just
started hanging out you know so
just and to be that big of a guy just to
kind of sneak up and just chill because
he seems like just like the most yeah I
just want to sit back and hang out until
either I have to act or beat the hell
out of somebody and that's like the only
two things that I like get them up I'd
like to annoy everyone Pullman I think
no no no I mean I definitely saw his I I
definitely know his thoughts on Studio
Executives at this point but you know I
do say that video is great yeah but I
got I gotta say I love the guy and I
think I I love them on Sons of Anarchy
like that was one of my go-to shows for
a very very long time so he's my boy uh
you know love love his work and uh yeah
but it yeah it was just trippy it was
just like Yep this is the kind of stuff
that just happens at these shows you
know random things yeah so he is Hellboy
they messed up
yeah Dave David Harbor I think got it
got uh you know had had a good shot at
it but I would I Ron perlman's my guy
for that I really love this one so I
wish I know they're not going to
necessarily make money off of it just
make the third one while Ron perlman's
still kicking like come on I know it's
tough it's tough but you know that's
that's the thing is when you're dealing
with Hollywood you're dealing with an
industry that is driven on bottom lines
and fear that's why you keep seeing all
these remakes and remakes and remakes
and remakes and you know recycled and
more of the same you know and
everybody's taking these big swings of
big gambles on these big IPS because
it's Hollywood is an entertainment
industry that is driven on risk analysis
and cost benefit analysis and what's
going to get shareholders the most money
it's not about art it's about
entertainment and entertainment is money
driven industry yeah
I I hope we can find an economical art
like somewhere some happy medium
eventually hopefully this will these
couple months or however long will be
end up in this strike kind of position
hopefully that'll push it towards that
direction but
we'll see I mean yeah I'm sorry go on no
no just with that thought that just
popped out we were kind of talking about
this a little bit yesterday on a little
movie Tuesday stream but with
barberheimer happening do you think
that's something like both fairly
expensive but they're not like expensive
and like your Marvel or DC kind of sin
some big Star Wars project something
like that close not too too far off but
they're they're not independent projects
because they're big Studio Temple films
but they're like right next door in a in
a way you know well it's I
I mean it's it's so funny that you
associate something that's like not a
guaranteed project you know as like
indep like almost it almost gets viewed
in the same category as independent
films it's not you know
yeah I mean these these uh you know
Barbie's budget when you factor in how
much they spent on marketing was over
300 million and they still broke it in
the first weekend like they made they
they made it back and these and these
days people only really give a damn
about the the opening week in box office
because they know that the the drop-off
is precipitous after that you know
um
but uh yeah you get uh
you get these gigantic budgets but uh
and and
a lot a lot of people realize don't
realize is that the marketing budgets
are sometimes bigger than the actual
production budgets you know it's like to
get to get some of these movies out you
know they spent uh I think in Barbie it
was about an even split where the the
whole budget came out to be about 300
million or so uh but they that was that
was 150 million or 150 million dollar
marketing budget and uh hitting 334 like
they did means that they uh they
actually
made back uh you know return an actual
profit on it um I'm sure Hollywood
accounting will still show that they are
that they had a huge loss and it was
tremendous failure for everybody
involved you know they haven't included
the paint cost yet you know yeah oh my
God yeah they haven't paid the pink tax
yet just wait until that comes out okay
next I wonder how much thing and which
of that came out just paying Bobby
though I've been playing Mattel that
that must have cost of because I know a
couple of people have seen it now I know
Harris you said you've seen it yeah
they've took their kids expecting a
Barbie film and the parent the kids have
come away going what the hell was that
and the parents have got him I don't
know but they must have paid Mattel a
fortune
if I recall correctly the industry
standards somewhere around 10 to 15 so
yeah that makes sense but do you think
Mattel would have put that money back
into the movie Just with how much have
you seen it Greg I have not seen it yet
uh we're gonna go do our barberheimer
experience uh this coming weekend I
think so we're Jen and I like to go
after things have been out for a little
bit just to avoid I like I I don't like
dealing with crowds yeah so yeah okay an
Oppenheimer
because it's a Chris Nolan film yeah I
mean that's why that was even made in
the first place I I I've always thought
that um I've seen a lot of Articles
describe him as an IP unlike himself and
yeah I I like that that makes sense him
Tarantino Spielberg scorses
etc etc they're kind of yeah he's built
up he's built up his own brand to be
like you know the the the the the next
in in the long of generational directors
you know and that's uh and and seriously
it's those reputations that that's how
movies get made you want to know how
Zack Snyder keeps getting jobs like what
love him or hate him JJ Abrams these
guys have these reputations as
trustworthy box office Banks and that's
and that's why uh they keep getting
um they they keep getting film screen
lit and that's why they keep getting
involved and stuff now I don't know how
much uh JJ I don't know how much uh
Zach's star has fallen uh with
everything with the DCU and everything
um but uh you know for for years and
years and years he's getting all these
movies because he'd built up a
reputation for himself as someone who
can deliver and you know that's
Hollywood will uh Hollywood
thrives on that reliability they need to
have that reliability so you know for
anybody who's looking to break into the
industry
get build yourself a reputation as
someone who is a reliable person someone
will show up on time someone who will do
the job right someone who you know uh
doesn't cause problem stays in their
Lane and everything and then is willing
to learn and work your way up and
eventually you'll start getting creative
opportunities you know
um that you know like that's and it's
like that at all levels of of uh
creative and collaborative Arts because
you know it's like that with us with
small theater we don't make any money in
small theater like that's that's no joke
I'm an actor's Equity member that makes
no money every year uh because you know
the projects that I really love to do
and the project spend my time and effort
on are all very small projects but even
still we uh you know I have a group of
people that I like to work with because
I know they're reliable they don't cause
problems we collaborate well together
you know there's a reason why Kevin
Smith keeps working with all the same
people there's a reason why Zack Snyder
keeps working with all the same people
there's a reason why Guillermo del Toro
has Ron Perlman in everything he does
it's because when you find collaborators
that are reliable that are bankable you
don't want to give that up you know so
that is uh and and it's like that
throughout Hollywood I think is very
very drivable you know in that regard
we talk about Stargate on our Channel
quite a lot
um but it's I've got a couple of people
that I've been lucky enough to be able
to talk to about this and the thing that
really shocked me because I didn't know
much about the film industry before I
started doing this Channel and the thing
that really shocked me is how much
marketing and PR and just and the amount
of like um research they do and they're
asked their opinion Executives at the
studios constantly asking this one quite
big marketing company with their opinion
and everything before they do anything
they have like
surveys and all this done to try to if
we announce it now how will people react
and if we do this now how will people
and I'm sort of like where's the
creative side of it where's the it's our
original mitigation it's 100 risk of
mitigation this is why they have test
screenings this is why they go back and
do reshoots on test screenings uh and
the thing is is that you know if you're
an executive your job depends on how
well the movies that you approved
perform so of course you know when
you're talking about you know hundreds
of millions to even billions of dollars
in revenue for the company and
everything that level of pressure yeah
of course there's going to be a certain
amount of of uh you know uh like being
an extra cook in the kitchen and trying
to make sure the steel comes out great
and the problem is is that
I think that as a result
um there's a lot of stuff in Hollywood
that they try to make for the widest
audience possible they try to appeal to
everyone so therefore it appeals to
basically no one or the absolute lowest
common denominator which is why we have
10 Fast and the Furious movies you know
like you know big explosions big guns
big you know and hey don't get me wrong
I like me a good action popcorn flick I
really enjoyed I enjoyed uh dial of
Destiny I we went and saw that last week
I enjoyed it you know I was like I have
I have I have some issues with with
certain aspects of it but uh you know it
was it was a good time and I like me you
know I'm I'm a huge fan of Die Hard we
do a very die hard Christmas Christmas
at my theater every year musical parody
of Die Hard you know like we're we're
here yeah for real oh it's a good time
it's a lot of fun
um
uh you know I don't know if Bruce Willis
actually sold his digital like this for
for stuff but I know that they've got
enough full body scans of him that all
he's got to do is sign the papers at
this point and it and uh they'd have it
uh they did that with Harrison Ford yeah
um they did that with Harrison Ford
especially for uh for everything that
they did with dial of Destiny and all
the de-aging and stuff like that and he
was as he put it he was very well
compensated for that you know and uh
James Earl Jones has signed over his
voice to be uh for for the use of Darth
Vader he signed that over for millions
of dollars and that's great you know
when an actor like that can get a Payday
like that that guarantees that their
children their grandchildren whatever
they'll all be well taken care of
fantastic it's you know I don't I don't
have a problem with that the problem
that I have is with when they're doing
it to uh background actors where they'll
pay them for you know 172 for eight and
uh get a full body scan in them and then
never hire them again because now
they've got uh licensed to use their
digital likeness and in perpetuity in
whatever project they want that's that's
that's the direction that this is
heading in very rapidly and that's part
of the reason why we're on strike yeah I
I saw a great video last week about that
and it gave the example of if this was
happening in the early 90s think about
Matt Damon and Ben Affleck who you know
best friends did a bunch of stuff
together yada yada yada they were extras
in Field of Dreams if they would have
signed their likeness away
we wouldn't know who Matt Damon and Ben
Affleck are today you have no idea yeah
royalties to somebody if they if they
did a movie yeah oh my God if you were
trying to use your own likeness in your
own project and you were getting sued
because technically the studio owns your
face Universal owns it
okay that's messed up that's messed up
like yeah wow and and it wouldn't
surprise me if there were things in a
contract that would literally box you
out of the industry so you couldn't work
on something that wasn't approved by the
people that you signed your likeness
over to you know that's cool yeah I mean
that's what they want to do what if they
want to do Bloody horror movies we don't
think that's good for your brand yeah
yeah
you mean you mean the brand of the
digital likeness where all the money
goes to you because yeah the digital
likeness they could say well we don't
want you to do that because we're on
your likeness
um I'm like that it's interesting but
the government could step in here the
government could do a law and I think
they should have done it years ago
the problem is is that you know with
with the repeal of glass steel back and
the 90s and all these other things that
have happened like the you know
corporations have uh basically been
taking back more and more and more power
through deregulation and as a result
they can get away with more now you know
I'm a small business owner I think that
there's a lot of stupid regulations out
there that regulate uh that business
that regulate businesses that I think
are a giant pain in the ass or wrong you
know but there's
there are things that are allowed to
happen now because of deregulation that
are very anti-capitalist and very
anti-competitive where you have all
these vertical Integrations uh you know
one of the I went to a panel of
Comic-Con this year about what uh the
the it was called The Writer's Journey
but basically was talking about what the
market for writers uh screenwriters
might look like after the strike and
they talked about the mini rooms they
talked about or reduced show orders they
talked about record profits in spite of
of smaller show orders you know they've
talked about uh all the all the not even
getting into AI a lot of people didn't
want to talk about AI at the show a lot
of people did like I was at a visual
design panel and they didn't they were
like you know we talked about this and
if they got asked about AI they were
like you know we talked about this in
advance we said we're not going to touch
this topic you know and they were Point
Blank about it and I've heard why later
and it was chilling and I'll get into
that in a second that's a little talking
out of school but
um
but you know I'm in this panel and they
talked about like okay
you know you want to you want to work on
a show for Warner Brothers you want to
work on a show for CW you want to work
on the show for this network or that and
they put up a chart
of what
what corporations own what business is
and the vertical Integrations not just
in like media but or like not not just
in like TV but in like branching out
into film into podcasts into internet
content into everything journalism news
networks everybody's owned by like for
you know I want to say like I think it's
like seven corporations pretty much own
everything in the world and that's
uh you know that's a lot that's that's
that's a lot of power that all this
stuff was there to try and prevent and
it's very anti-competitive
um you know capitalism thrives on
competition and you know they want to
talk about how profits and everything uh
are what uh you know are are what drives
the world and what drives the business
and you know greed is good uh but
it's it's anti-competitive when when the
biggest guys can can shove everybody
else out of the pool or drown them you
know and that's that's where we're
that's where we are right now because
you know you have you you if you watch
coverage of the strikes on the news
networks it's all pretty biased it's a
lot of like you know why are these
actors why are these writers you know
they're they're striking again you know
because they're not getting paid fair
whatever you know you get this you get
you get a little bit of a slant on it
and it's because
you know the news networks are owned by
the studios yeah you know and like who
who's whose point of view do you think
they're going to be delivering you know
I mean you could be the most liberal you
know you know TV network in the world
but you know when when you're told that
this is the story that you're running
that kind of like questions the
legitimate legitimacy of a strike or
questions uh you know like do they
really need this you know we in the last
15 years we've watched the middle class
actor disappear
um yeah yeah there isn't anymore but you
want because you know you had uh you
know movies are struggling movies are
failing because they keep rehashing the
same old [__] over and over and over
again going like why don't people want
this anymore you wanted it 10 minutes
ago and it's like dude we can't have ice
cream for breakfast every day you know
you gotta like you gotta switch it up
just Saturdays yeah just Saturdays I
mean you know but that's but and there's
there's
there's a real um I mean I know I'm
bouncing all over the place here you
know I'm all but this is this is all
it's it's all
uh an ecosystem that is in crisis at the
moment because we have you know there's
so many things happening that are all
interconnected and it's all been leading
up to this stuff uh you know we we have
in in the TV world right now
um you have the Stars a lot of folks
you've had a lot of folks who used to be
movie stars or are movie stars also
doing television at the moment which hey
great problem even Harrison Ford yeah
Harrison Ford uh doing uh shrinking you
know a friend of mine CJ Hook is a
writer on that and she's you know she's
speaks nothing but wonderful things
about everybody involved in that show
like I am so envious of her for so long
I just haven't sat down to do it I need
to so bad yeah well we're in a golden
age of television at the moment where I
mean ironically with as we're talking
about all this stuff we're in a golden
age of Television immediate at the
moment where there's more stuff than
ever uh
there's more opportunity than ever at
the moment which is which is true but at
the same time uh we're dealing with
um
you know shorter series shorter runs you
know and this is this there's uh
my gosh which which angle do I attack
this from first uh season length is one
of the issues okay it used to be that
that an average season of Television let
me talk about this from The Writer's
perspective real quick now I am let me
preface this I am not a member of the
wga I am a member of sag after an
actor's equity and I'm a member of the
dramata skill so the dramatist guild is
like the wga but for playwrights okay so
I that that's not a and it's not a
one-to-one comparison but that's just
like the drama this Guild does does
theater because I've been working in
theater ever since I was a kid you know
but now I'm uh and and I've I like to
think that I've I've built a nice career
for myself within theater and I've been
working uh for a while now to get back
working on screen again my ultimate goal
is to be doing one hour dramas and while
there is a lot of big stuff happening
you know you get all these streamers
with you know the big IP shows you get
the Star Wars shows you get the Star
Trek shows you get the uh um oh my God
what else is really big right now like
there's so much uh well there's two or
three or four of each one of those just
yeah exactly I mean just just in those
alone yeah I mean there's there's
literally four different Star Trek
series on the air right now with one
that just was recently canceled now has
its own save the show uh yeah
um we uh the average TV season length
was around 20 to 25 episodes previously
and now uh now it's like anywhere from
six to ten episodes yeah so uh you know
a writer's room used to be 10 people
that would work on a 22 25 episode
season with each person you know with
them all working together to to develop
the season Arc and then each you know
each member in that room getting a
couple of scripts right now they would
get their normal salary plus they would
get a script uh script bonus every time
they wrote an episode that's script
bonus
it was not small you know it was like it
was like a five figure bonus uh that
they would get for for being the writer
on a script and that is how you know
when you got those jobs when you got
staffed up and you were a writer on a
show that is how you were making your
living was that you would have you'd
work you know you'd work 30 40 50 weeks
a year or 30 or 40 weeks a year on on
the show
and make your make your salary plus
bonuses every time you you were the lead
writer on a script
now the average and and that was about
10 writers now with show orders of
anywhere from Seven you know six to ten
episodes uh they've gone from writer's
rooms to what they call Mini rooms a
showrunner and maybe three writers
you know and those
um you know and those the you know the
salary is reduced you're you're you're
working maybe three to ten weeks as
opposed to 30 or 40 weeks of the year
so you're spending the rest of the year
you're hustling for work
um and you know that but that's when
you're when shows aren't hiring 10
writers when they're only hiring three
writers that's a 70 loss of the job
market
yeah that's that's a very like uh and on
top of that once again when Hollywood's
got their favorites when they've got
their show Runners that they like when
they've got their Ryan Murphy's when
they've got their Shonda Rhimes is when
they've got their when they've got their
people with these insane overall years
they're JJ Abrams uh these are the guys
who get the the top show running
things and our you know show writing
opportunities and get to build their
versus their universes and everything
else uh
and while there are more shows out there
there's less opportunity and there's
less opportunity for career advancement
Beyond being a staff writer because
those you know the if you thought that
there were fewer uh writer opportunities
there's fewer showrunner opportunities
too because a lot of these things keep
going to the same people
um so it's you know that's that's
another big issue that they're trying to
deal with is the lack of upward mobility
in a career path like it's at one point
the latter got pulled up behind a
generation of people
and now there's it's very difficult to
find a path forward so again that's
another big reason for the strike many
rooms is one of the biggest reasons and
then we're talking you know and and on
top of that residuals and on top of that
I mean residuals on streaming uh you
know I I remember the strike in
2007-2008 I was you know and I've I when
I first got out here sag was on the
commercial strike in 2003 you know like
that that I so I've I've seen my fair
share strikes we done [__] up when we
didn't uh
when we did not
negotiate streaming when we had the
chance when we didn't negotiate better
streaming when we had the chance when we
let the studio say oh this is unproof of
Technology we don't know how this is
going to work we don't know this we
don't know that they're recording
billions and billions and billions of
dollars in record profits now gross not
net I understand the difference here you
know but they're they're they're
recording ridiculous amounts of gross
profits
um and giving shareholders dividends
which also I understand that's part of
the game like that's literally
like an important part of capitalism is
making sure that your shareholders get
paid because otherwise they won't invest
in you in which case you know the cycle
of money stops and the whole the whole
machine seizes up and you know crashes
can't have that like I understand at the
same time though don't [__] come and
and Report record profits out of one
side of your mouth to the shareholders
and be you know tossing out executive
bonuses and everything else and come to
the unions and plea poverty when what
we're asking for is a percentage of a
percentage of a percentage of what the
gross is you know for the work that we
do for the work that we did this is not
right this is not right you know when
when you've got these top Executives uh
making you know seven eight or you know
seven eight nine figures a year in their
executive compensation packages with
their Investments with their stock with
everything else when they get all when
they get all this stuff when these guys
are cruising around on Mega yachts and
just saying oh it's so unrealistic for
the writers to demand more you know go
[__] you yourself like seriously yeah
this is It's sorry I don't I I I get
very angry about this because this is
these are good hard work and people just
trying to build an opportunity for
themselves and do something that they're
passionate about and care about like
isn't that the American dream to be able
to make a living and to do what we love
you know definition of yeah and it used
to be such a great place to go do it
like yeah but you're saying that the
middle class has disappeared and kind of
a lot of ways everywhere but
particularly in this industry and it's
just easy to see and yeah and just just
to touch on that super fast just to
illustrate the point you get these TV
you get these film actors coming in
coming in being leads on TV shows uh
great they get a big payday but they get
such a big payday that the rest of the
budget is non-existent so everybody else
on the show winds up working for scale
even get even guest stars multi-episode
guest stars work for scale there's no
room in the budget to give somebody you
know to pay them more based on their
experience based on whatever scale is as
good as you get in scale for those of
you not in the industry is literally the
minimum person yeah the minimum the
minimum rate per tier so that uh
you know like they've they've allocated
all the star power though because now
it's like oh my God Lawrence Fishburne
on you know doing a TV show Harrison
Ford doing a TV show all these you know
these these these movie actors coming
and I'm not I'm not mad at that
everybody's got to work everybody's got
to eat and you gotta you want to scratch
your creativity go for it but we have to
look at what the numbers say and the
numbers say that this is hurting the
little guy and you know that's what
these strikes are about my brother years
and years ago during during the previous
strike my brother calls me up and uh
he's like why why are you guys striking
he's he's against unions in general you
know and I understand there are people
who are out there that are like that and
that's fine you can be wrong that's okay
uh but
um
he's uh he's like what does Tom Cruise
need another private island is that why
you guys are striking I'm like yeah
because because he didn't get a private
island is why I'm going out walking in
110 degree heat in the sun you know
doing laps around NBC Universal yeah
because I give a [__] about his private
island yeah burning signs no shade
nothing exactly
it's never been about the one percent
it's about the it's about everybody
else's name it's about yeah it's about
everybody else it's about everybody else
who who and and the thing is just like
yeah you know this industry is hard
enough as it is you know we have 87
percent of uh the membership of sag
after it doesn't qualify for the minimum
for health insurance that's 26 000 a
year you don't make twenty six thousand
dollars a year as professional actor uh
87 of the union doesn't qualify uh it
doesn't make that so they can't qualify
for health insurance and that's because
uh you know it used to be that if you
got a guest star your residuals
um you know your your salary plus your
residuals would be enough to cover that
you know one guest star could do that
for you you know for uh and and now I
think it's very telling when you have
stars of shows going out and showing
their residuals and they're getting
pennies for uh for quarterly unlimited
streaming use you know and uh of of
their shows you know they're getting
pennies for unlimited streaming for for
90 days like that's
if that's not indicative of what the big
problems here are I I don't know what it
is but I mean as a writer though if
you're not getting paid in your best
work or even worse
are the best writers
going elsewhere maybe even doing
something else I know a lot of I know a
lot of TV writers who have pivoted to
comic books um that's why they were
that's why a lot of them were Comic-Con
I got a couple of friends of mine who
are TV writers who are writing for
Marvel right now who are writing for DC
like they're you know it's it's the
comic book division is not a struck
company you know so they can they can
they can they can work in that you know
um
but you know and everybody's everybody's
got to make their money but the thing is
is that this industry you can't you
can't phone it in you can't hone it in
because if you get a reputation for
phone again you'll never work again you
know I mean that's the thing is that we
because this industry is so competitive
because everything is so Cutthroat
because the studios know and rely on the
fact that if you don't give your A game
uh for for this [__] pay they can get
somebody else to do it they'll bring it
they'll just bring they'll get rid of
you and bring in somebody else and most
times yeah
you have to keep giving your best you
have to keep putting out your your A
game in spite of the indignities of
these ridiculously low uh you know
paychecks and in spite of uh of
everything else because they know
because you know that if this is your
opportunity you know and you're chasing
that Brass Ring like you got to eat some
[__] on the way up the mountain here
that's so many metaphors sorry uh but
you got you got to keep Jackson I got
you yeah you know what's up so we got a
you you can't just phone it in
unfortunately everybody's got to give
their a game or you get replaced because
it's it's that easy you know your
reputation can take decades to build in
only seconds to ruin
I think a lot of people I'm sorry I
think a lot of people would argue that a
lot of the writing particularly on some
streaming shows hasn't been
as good as it used to be because I I
would argue I I mean don't get me wrong
I I had plenty of issues with book of
Boba Fett you know um you know like
dances with Panthers was quite the uh
quite the experience you know uh but uh
I I would argue that that's actually due
to
um the overburdening of the writers in
the reduced workloads or I mean the
reduced number of writers and
collaborators
um you know in the room the lack of the
lack of collaborative talent I mean I I
feel like that that was you know Peak
like mini rooms and stuff like that
where where you had fewer fewer people
contributing and fewer people working
together and the and the they still had
you know you had three or four people
trying to turn out uh you know a whole
what was it six eight episodes you know
that's that's a lot of work and a lot of
pressure especially when one of them's
the showrunner who's also basically
doing executive producer duties you know
um in addition to dealing with all the
writers uh they're they're I I feel like
that if you're if you feel like that the
quality of work is suffering it's
because of fewer collaborators and
because of um you know greater workload
and greater expectations you can't
you can't constantly be running at a
hundred percent you know so you saw this
or the and one of the things they used
to do is they would write almost up to
filming so I mean I know on Star Trek I
was watching them one of the greatest
things sometimes we'd be typing away in
the morning and we'd still be bouncing
ideas off each other things but nowadays
they sort of want the script for
streaming shows anyway they want the
script done and locked down and agreed
by Executives before they start filming
and then they film and I've always
thought that's
because then if something doesn't work
on screen you're kind of stuck
well they also don't want to pay to have
a writer on set yeah that's exactly
because that's another cut cost right
there is not paying to have a writer on
set and I think that there's a lot of um
I was working background on a movie in
2008 during the writers strike and I
literally watched
um uh Sean William Scott and Paul Rudd
like the directors tell them oh just
just improvise we can't write anything
we can't do rewrites right now so if
it's not working just riff just riff you
know and there's
um
I think there's always a room a room for
a healthy amount of improvisation but
you know when you don't have a writer
there on set to fix something that's not
working and you have to rely on improv
like that's to do improv correctly you
have to have good context especially on
set for something like that you have to
have the context of the scene the
character the environment that both of
those things are in all that and that
allows you to like be able to improvise
like that without that
Good Luck Chuck you know like yeah yeah
and especially on like a Sci-Fi show
where you have all the Techno Babble and
everything else that gets even that gets
even crazier now I mean everybody has
their favorite story about oh my God
this this improvised moment that was
just so hilarious and so brilliant
for that one that like two second scrap
of Brilliance can you imagine the number
of takes they left on the floor you know
yeah
um and and and the amount of [__] that
didn't work you know Ryan Reynolds
apparently he's a nightmare he's
constantly like which is fine but it
means you get hours and hours and hours
of virtual nonsense yeah and they hit
that one golden thing and
um but I know like a lot of writers
though they don't particularly like it
when they go off off the streets as a
playwright I I have watched as people
have Rewritten my my plays on stage like
I sat in the audience and just watched
as people have deliberately changed my
words and does that Inspire or hurt
um
it depends on where the piece is because
there have been a couple of times where
you know I have I I have done a show and
I've watched rehearsals and I've watched
you know uh I've written a show and I'll
watch it in rehearsals and we'll we'll
get it on his feet and you know show
changes the minute there's an audience
in front of it like it there there is
that added there's that added
conversation that happens and you see
what works and you see what doesn't and
um especially when I've taken stuff to
The Fringe festivals
um I will always do rewrites on the
script afterwards and 99 of the time the
changes that I'm making are changes that
uh that were made during the run
something that an actor found uh but you
know there there have been times though
when I'm like okay this script is set
I'm very happy with where the script is
just say the [__] words yeah and they
can't you know and and they can't or
won't do it and at that point it's it's
it drives me insane so you know it I
think it just depends on the kind of
conversation that or it depends on the
state of the piece and and it depends on
the preference of the uh of the the
collaborators involved you know that
makes sense so think about that you made
me think of it just a second ago if if
you're acting would you rather be on set
with someone that does Stanley Kubrick
and takes 80 90 100 different takes or
would you rather Clint Eastwood where
he's notorious for one and done
do you think there's a do you I think I
I don't I I I I I I I don't think that
well if I would love to be one and done
I really would at the same time
um
uh I'm no I'm no Kubrick but when I do
my own self tapes I'm like I'm gonna get
this done in two and it'll be ten takes
you know uh because shit's always gonna
happen
um you know so I I I I want to lean
towards the fewer is better but I know
in practicality and if I'm being honest
with myself that I know that I do
multiple takes for everything and that
is uh you know like yeah I have tons of
unused footage and and and and screw-ups
and everything at one point it would be
fun to actually put together like a
blooper reel from all of my auditions
yeah yeah
um but you know I do think that there is
a happy medium I really do uh I A friend
of mine was a writer on uh only murders
in the building and season three trailer
just came out today I need to watch it
I'm very excited I'm very very excited
speaking of Paul Rudd uh yeah uh I I'm
very excited for it but I remember uh
him telling me that you know he was
standing around on set this was he was
one of the few writers that was like you
know like on set when things were gone
and he said that uh that Steve Martin in
particular was great he would make sure
that he would do the he would do at
least two takes by the book and be like
you got it you happy you know you you
know that he do it as written and then
he would go do we have time for me to
try something
yeah
and you know that's when he would do
that's when he would he was
improvisational like let me [__] around
and see what we could find here take
let's go dig it for some Golden Empire
Hills and uh the writers were like you
know we got what we wanted and then and
then sometimes you know you'd have
someone who could Elevate that material
and do something else with it but they
would but he always I think he did it
right because he always made sure that
they had what they needed
before he went to see if they could find
something else that they wanted you know
and that I think is doing it right
you know and I mean when you've got a
comic genius like Steve Martin are you
really gonna tell the guy no but he's
not so he's not so presumptuous to think
to to behave like well I know better
than the writers he still respects the
other artists I mean yeah
like respect's another actor you should
respect the writers you should expect
the guy doing the lights for God's sake
because obviously skill I might be
throwing people my age under the bus but
do you think that's partially a
generational thing no I think it's an
ego thing
because you want to know why because
I've seen enough I've seen enough old
[__] to know that it's not just you
know it's not Zoomers it's not just
Zoomers you know it's everybody you know
um and I've seen people in my own
generation who like in small theater
I've seen people like take my words and
be like oh I could do this so much
better you know and then proceed to to
mangle them you know directors and
actors alike to the point where at one
point I was like say what I wrote on the
[__] page or I'm gonna pull the show
you know like because if you want to put
up your own show you want to do your own
thing that's fine but don't have my name
on this yeah yeah it loses um what it
was at a certain point yeah exactly so
do I sound like Paul Rudd I don't I
anyway
I would say many things about you Harris
but I don't know if I'd ever accuse you
of that I don't I don't think so I wish
I had Paul Rudd's vampirism though let
me be 45 and still look like I'm my age
right now he's over 50 now
yeah yeah
I know and he looks like that that's not
that's not right what i'm friends 13
years ago my question is where is he
finding the blood of virgins in this
town yeah where's that adrenochrome or
whatever the things are oh God
such a funny conspiracy thing that went
wrong for a bit oh God the set no the
sad part is is still going and they're
oh yeah I don't know if that's ever
going to stop technically no because
anti-Semitism is real and it's awful and
it's you know yeah the God gross just in
the world is just ridiculous and just
it's a waste of time
yeah people get so angry about the most
ridiculous things I'm so like it's not
it's either not in your business or
really does it hurt you and my mum
always says look and I take all my
advice from my mum obviously because
she'd beat me otherwise as you should
you know it's just like if does it hurt
you
if it doesn't hurt you don't bother
don't worry about it you're doing you're
hurting yourself all you're doing is
putting your own heart rate up just
leave it yeah I try to live my life like
that it doesn't bother me it doesn't
matter leave it there's a lot of you
know there's the problem is that there's
a lot of money in Outrage
you know I'll hate Clips YouTube You're
monitoring as well you know I mean
there's there's a whole News Network
built around that so you know I mean
yeah
anyways to subscribers just go start
yelling at stuff yeah you see it's quite
easy to do if you if you've got no
morals and don't care yeah I mean
exactly all the news networks do it but
there's like there's a good chunk of
YouTube that does it too oh my God yeah
oh my God and it's worse because it's
uncensored you know yeah yeah
you can just lie on YouTube and really
there isn't a lot to to stop you I mean
you've just got to be careful you avoid
certain keywords and things and everyone
get pulled up on it yeah exactly yeah
and everybody knows the workarounds
that's that's the thing is that you know
they're the you know you know the ways
to get around it don't cuss too early in
the videos Do not cuss at all in that
first minute yeah and there are two c
words they don't like the the other word
for The Rona and then and then
see you next Tuesday of course that's my
favorite one a little more British you
know although the Australians get away
with that one just fine so they do just
fine if you're Carl Urban you can say it
anywhere all the time
it's basically like the word the for
color yeah it's legit Carl Urban is my
my spirit animal I I strive to beat Carl
Urban on a daily basis everything he's
ever done you see that almost human he
did they only did about 10 episodes
maybe it's one of the best sci-fi shows
and they got canceled if you need
someone just absolutely solid to be in
like a franchise and like make your
franchise first of all bankable second
of all just like have that good of an
actor that's just solid no matter what
but also brings all the the other actors
around them like up to that kind of
level if not even better Carl Urban just
Carlos
you know he's just excellent in
everything he does likable
he's one of those actors you'd go I'd
have a beer with Carl open and we're
back we'd get on great the people you
actually generally it just it just seems
like
you know you would say hello to him if
you saw him something I'm not sure I
would whatever if I saw Robert De Niro I
would just go
I wouldn't go and say hello to him
I think I've told you before I sat uh
next or sat behind Wes Anderson at a
Japanese uh little uh restaurant out
here one time and I I was kind of like
you know I'm a Texas boy surprise uh and
Wes Anderson is texting as it can as you
can be while being that like artistic I
guess so I was like
he's from Austin didn't he uh no he's
he's uh uh I think I think it's Houston
I want to say he's either Dallas or
Houston he's one of the two uh because
there are so I forget
because Owen Wilson and Luke Wilson are
from the other one which usually Dallas
and Houston are little Rivals you know
so they're kind of like yeah yeah but
they bridge the gap together so it's
sort of like the AL West right now you
know so yeah yeah yeah
um objects and mirror are closer than
they appear
don't get me started on objects and
mirror you saw me at the beginning I
screwed up already I demired myself so I
wouldn't be as confused just a few
things I thought you said Wes Cravings
do you not say Wes craving who you sat
behind
oh Wes Anderson I always do that I did
that last time I think so uh Wes
Craven's great but I I do prefer Wes
Anderson just because I do like me some
Wes Anderson I mean you know the guy uh
used to his you know I I enjoy his
visual signature you know the shot
competitions he's he's he's like he's
like Our Generations Kubrick in that
regard you know where every shot's a
painting you know totally uh
Barbie almost reminded me of it in a lot
of ways it's not of course like as as
picturesque but there are certain spots
where like you could just take that
frame and you might think it's a Wes
Anderson film in a way I think part of
that is because they you know that they
did the little 1940s 1950s thing with
all the Barbie houses where none of them
are actually like full-on houses you can
kind of pan out and put some cable
somewhere and toss them out the side or
Arvin go uh go down her slide to her
pool right next to her house something
like that but it's like a 1940s facade
type set you know nice I I I like the
way they handled that I'm I'm very
excited to see it I think that you know
at first I wasn't that interested I was
like oh Barbie movie is going to be for
kids but you know I think the more I've
heard people talk about it the more I'm
like all right now I feel like that this
is something that you know deserves
attention so you know gerwick and
bombach are just perfect you know
they're they're too damn good I the
movie's not as great necessarily as I
wanted it to be but it's it's not saying
it's not great because it is uh I I
think it does the best whenever it's
just like a a human existentialism kind
of thing where it's like what's it like
to be a human
it pisses people off where it's like
matriarchy versus patriarchy but like it
has to go that deep on both sides and
kind of like piss you off on both sides
to bring that point home at the end
I don't know if everybody's getting that
point at the end but it's confusing a
lot of young children
coming out going what the hell was that
and Aunt your your teenage Barbie movie
it is an existential human crisis and
the very final line in the film is
[__] hilarious uh so I'm I'm very
excited to go check this out now
it's like a Teddy Ruxpin film that
explores racism or something
now we're gonna have um I mean but now
Mattel is cracking open uh the Vault
here and pulling out every IP that
they've got and they're gonna be working
now their goal is to put out more movies
like this so this will be this will be
interesting you know
I just I I wonder the route too uh that
they're gonna take because gerwig's
already said she has no plans for a
sequel or anything and I didn't really
expect her to she doesn't seem like
someone that's like give me a sequel I
want to do this even though not
everything has to be a franchise you
know yeah well it was the house broke oh
no no it didn't yeah
you know I mean I I still want to see uh
you know I I was about to say I want to
see another d d movie because I love the
dungeons of dragons movie
I loved it I thought it was fantastic
and you got to realize that I was there
in costume for the first d d movie back
in 2000 and was sorely disappointed like
I was like oh my God it was oh come on
when he drops his knees no snails come
on yeah no oh come on yeah yeah yeah uh
but I I I'm I'm of the mind that d d or
dungeons Dragon shouldn't be a movie it
should actually be an anthology series a
la American Horror Story you know um no
I like that idea well I I I'm not
familiar enough with it Dungeons and
Dragons is the thing that I would
absolutely adore which I've never let
myself get fully into it because I would
I would devote life to it kind of [__]
you know
well I mean I'm a professional dungeon
master that's actually like one of my
hustles from when I was in here's my
books my dice my you know like that's
that's literally when when our theater
was closed down for eight 18 months
because of the Rona uh we you know my
wife got a job in education doing remote
education sales and I became a
professional game master I was running
games for people online around the world
and uh do that on Mondays right yeah I
still do that I still have a a twitch
stream every Monday night
um and uh you know it's been very
intermittent as of late but we're
picking back up and getting back into it
we've actually played two consecutive
weeks again for the first time in a
while which was fantastic like oh my God
we've missed each other so we're having
a lot of fun again uh but you know I
make I make decent money doing that uh
but yeah d d like because of the nature
of the way campaigns work how it's on
ongoing storytelling you know this would
uh
uh I see in the in the chat here Andrew
uh if you think that that the movie had
too much force comedy it's literally uh
it's literally that movie was literally
the embodiment of a of somebody's home
game so yeah if it's forced comedy it's
because the players were being awkward
you know behind the screen and if you if
you understand how the Dynamics work
it's pretty brilliant so I thought that
it worked on multiple levels because of
that yeah it's always opinion in it but
I genuinely feel it
my wife came out actually went that was
brilliant you made me come to this I was
dragged to and it's not my wife's normal
cup of tea but it was just a genuinely
enjoyable movie it was well written it
was well acted everything about it was I
thought it's perfect Cinema movie yeah
epically high stakes and uh you know
epically stupid Heroes you know and and
just just you put them all together and
just see what happens and that's
literally every they they joke about how
every campaign starts out with everybody
trying to be Lord of the Rings and it
devolves into like Adventure Time you
know or or something else ridiculous and
that's yeah dragons going down chasing
you down a big Mountainside or something
oh yeah absolutely and I I think that if
they were gonna do d d right they would
structure any sort of show very much
like an actual campaign where each
season
is uh is its own self-contained story
and then you could do your own MCU big
crossover after you reach a certain
point and have all these multiple plot
threads come together in an epic story
maybe that's when you do your feature
film you know like I I have
I have ideas and thoughts about this
because this would be there there's two
there's two IPS that I would kill to
work in and be a part of and that's Star
Trek and that's d d like those those are
my two those are my two dream IPS you
know to to be to be a part of and I
think that uh Dungeons and Dragons uh
Dungeons and Dragons is not served by
having just a two-hour film the stories
are too big you look at critical role uh
each critical role campaign uh is
hundreds and hundreds of hours each
episode is three to four hours long each
week you know that's four hours new
content every week for these shows uh
you know in just ongoing storyline and
each each campaign is about 130 140
episodes so you multiply that by three
or four you know like literally almost a
thousand hours of story you can't have
that condensed down into two hours
uh without sacrificing
what makes it it you know and I are and
you I think you could you could do it in
10 hours you could do it in 12 hours you
could do it I mean ideally 22 22 episode
season you know go back to go back to
big things and you have lots of
character development and you have you
know because you have all these side
plots you have B plots you have side
quests you have [__] getting derailed
you know and you have uh you have all
these things that create stakes and you
have all these things that that that
make it richer and then you have a big
epic payoff you know that would be the
idea uh both I am both uh I love me
lower ducks and strange new worlds uh I
would I would love to be on strange new
Worlds by if I had my pick of the shows
I would want to be on strange new worlds
but the crossover episode that just
dropped over the weekend was flipping
brilliant and I loved every second of it
my nerd heart just exploded uh with it I
think yeah it's stupidity it was I I
just don't have the the voice over
experience to feel like I could reliably
be on something like lower decks so and
they actually have a very very specific
style they even joke about it in the
crossover episode that everybody is so
that that that they acknowledge the fact
that they're very loud and very hyper
specific and very fast talking so I I
feel like I'd be better served on snw
than than um
um then lower decks so let me see when
we get Legacy there you go yeah I really
want Legacy I actually ran into Todd's
dashbook of Comic-Con well I didn't I
didn't actually say hi to him or
anything but we made eye contact and I
nodded and then he turned and walked
away so
but I ran it I ran into him uh I ran
into him at one of the hotels so that
was a glorious geek as well oh yeah I
was like dude I would I would DM for him
anytime he'd probably wrecked my table
that'd be amazing so
uh I'd see when you said crossover for a
second I was thinking that's that's is
that the musical episode I remember live
action thing yeah it comes out uh August
3rd the trailer for that okay okay yeah
I thought it was sooner than later
because everyone's talking about it so
much
dropped and everybody's freaking out
about it so yeah that uh yeah
um didn't look great it's it's gonna be
dope so very excited for it hopefully
not looking forward to it but we'll see
and but I just don't like musicals like
that's that's a personal issue with it
I'm I'm an I'm an old school musical
theater geek so I I'm all about like
okay you know if I I think that I've
seen it you know ever since Buffy did it
I feel like a lot of people have tried
to pull it off and have failed I do have
faith though that Star Trek could do it
right and I'd be very intrigued to see
what happens here so one of the uh
because I've talked about this a couple
of times on my channel and one of the
things I've sort of think of what I
think people are annoyed is because we
only get 10 strange new worlds episodes
so it's like yeah Star Trek real estate
is quite valuable we get 10 hours so
yeah we've already had one quirky
episode we've had the crossover episode
we've had a comedy episode with the
Spock episode or it becomes human oh
brilliant episodes don't get me wrong
the only bad episode of ABS this this
season so far was the first episode was
not very good but other than that
they've been brilliant
um but I just think it's one too many
quick episodes that quite like a Star
Trek episode now I've quite like three
proper Star Trek episodes running since
next and do a music or
do a surprise 11th episode which is the
musical and then I don't think so many
people would have been not so annoyed
well you know but this is why more
episodes are better you know like if if
and this is why you need more writers
and this is why you need to pay the
writers and this is why you know like
like I feel like that
you know I I watched Star Trek the Next
Generation again during uh during the
pandemic and we watched we got through
most Deep Space Nine as well those were
22 24 episode Seasons 26 episodes
sometimes and not every episode was a
home run but they were uh
but there was a lot of damn good
television there so you can't tell me
that uh that uh more episodes means
lower quality yeah that's not I don't
think that's the case I think you get
the right you get the right writers you
get the right groups uh you get more
people involved and you're gonna uh you
know then it doesn't feel like they're
trying to cram
50 pounds of [__] in a 10 pound bag you
know so every season of Television
nowadays feels like it's trying to be
both both lengthwise and I guess
gravitas wise like a mini series and
yeah you have to do that and just enjoy
what you're right we kind of missed the
Filler episodes as well because one of
the Filler episodes are doing quite well
just to give the actors a bit of a break
or let the writers catch up a little bit
we have this little filler episode but
when they were done well because we were
talking about Stargate did a couple of
Filler episodes but what they did was
there was a new president
yeah he was being told that like the
reports from from all these missions and
then they'd have little flashbacks and
they were so such this is great like
remember but Star Trek would have the
odd little filler episode or an episode
that was just based around one character
or this sort of thing and it gave that
actor that that actor got like that's my
episode sort of thing and yeah yeah
development and stuff and those episodes
they're lacking because there isn't
enough time like I say and I just think
three quirky funny episodes in Star Trek
is
when you've only got 10 episodes It's
one too many
amazing
there were 13 would it be like the happy
medium kinda
I don't know I I like that 13 through 16
a lot uh because 22 to 26 could be a lot
and end up with a couple it depends on
it depends on the format of the show I
think uh because you know next
generation was for for so much of it was
monster of the week you know and yeah it
felt like every season especially
towards the end there it was like oh
this is the episode this season where
Troy loses her powers this is the
episode where the Roxanna shows up this
is the episode where you know like the
this is the Klingon episode you know and
they always have like these these
fallbacks of like okay this is this is
the time that we're doing that this year
uh but
um
you know I feel like
10 can be like when it's monster of the
week you could do as many of these as
you want as long as you got inspiration
you know when you're trying to do this
ongoing serialized episodic storytelling
where it's one ongoing storyline yeah
that's when you get to eight to ten
episodes and like what was it was like
the first daredevil on Netflix like
watching that
um it was like some brilliant stuff some
amazing stuff that hallway fight is
still top 10 all the time of just like
some of the best television fights on
television
The Punisher hallway fight too yeah
um but you know if I remember people
being like Oh my God it's so good except
for like these two episodes in the
middle just feel like a slog like they
just had to write something to fill it
in you know and uh so I think that if
you're trying to tell big overarching
storyline
um
you got to make sure that you have
enough material to fill out the episode
order and and and have it be good and
that's where you can start feeling like
you can see the stress lines and you
start seeing the fatigue uh pecan season
two they're saying they basically it was
three episodes of Star Trek spread over
10 episodes
and you can actually see it that at
times you're thinking they don't know
what they're doing with this they've
just they're doing an episode they're
just they're just padding time a little
bit a little bit Yeah so and and but
that that's the trouble when you have uh
like the ongoing serialized stuff uh but
you know uh I think that
um you know and then and then there are
times where you know of I'm I'm friends
with one of the uh one of the head folks
on Ted lasso and uh they said that with
season two uh they had a 10 episode
order and they they wrote The 10
episodes and they started shooting the
10 episodes and then then Apple came
back and said oh you're getting two more
they're like
hold on no no no no like I don't think
you understand we wrote how how are we
gonna do this so they basically wrote
two bottle episodes and one of them was
the Christmas episode the other one was
uh beards night out and the Christmas
episode wholesome fun everybody loved it
and I know that Beard's night out was
very divisive people either loved it or
they hated it you know I found it a bit
boring I don't think I watched all of it
it was just a bit it was just a bit like
if you this feels like an hour
Brendan Brendan hunt who uh played coach
beard he's an LA theater guy and I've
seen like and he was he was the guy who
I want I want to say that he was one of
the guys who was heading up writing that
episode if you've ever seen any of his
plays or if you know him at all like
that and that episode was just like so
rewarding because it was basically like
him you know and it was hilarious and
absurd and insane I mean I I he did he
wrote a peanuts parody where he played
pig pen on unnamed uh you know an
unnamed Pig Pen uh and hula hoop naked
like that was uh that was he did that at
The Fringe Festival in 2013 out here and
he uh so you know he's he's already a
little little twisted and a little out
there and just getting to see him do it
do an episode that was that expanded on
this this character and did it in such
an interesting way and did it in such a
Brendan way it was like you don't get
those opportunities very often you know
but I thought it was very wise of them
to do bottle episodes that kind of give
you a little bit more insight into the
characters to give you some feel-good
moments or whatever then try to stretch
material and shoehorn them in
um instead of cutting four episodes or
two episodes into four yeah yeah exactly
so you know I I thought that that was
that was the good thing to do because
you know and and this is this is you
know Star Trek X-Files all these shows
they used to be monster of the week
episodic every episode self-contained
you know and you have a big reset at the
end of it which you know kind of kills
interesting character development when
you have big character moments and it's
like oh no it's just like that this is
not going to be a lasting change for the
character you know I really feel like
that we had a couple of storylines in
Next Generation where you had carry over
obviously the Borg and obviously you
know you had recurring characters like q
and things like that but you didn't have
truly serialized storytelling until we
got to later later seasons is Deep Space
Nine mostly because that wasn't part of
roddenberry's vision you know so
and uh you know in Deep Space Nine kind
of especially in the later Seasons kind
of [__] off and went off and did
whatever it wanted to uh whereas Voyager
was still beholden to uh what the vision
was that's why Europe hell was only two
episodes instead of a full season you
know so like there's uh
uh I I think that there's something to
be said for both styles of Storytelling
um I think that when you you you have to
decide like everybody wants to do the
serialized ongoing stuff uh at the
moment and that's really where where we
get these shorter mini series you know
uh six eight ten episodes I uh but
we're now missing the the job
opportunities that come from the bigger
sprawling monster of the week you know
like self-contained uh opportunities
that's that's not that's not the style
of Storytelling we're doing right now so
yeah
so yeah
well just think about that someone
mentioned Game of Thrones with only 10
episodes a season and that's because it
kind of follows that it's not a mini
series by any means yeah but like it's
not a book per season either but it's
it's along those lines where they have a
full narrative they're telling the
narrative they know the amount of time
they need they make it make sense in
that time that they know that they need
Etc uh until you know until you notice
when they started slowing down because
like well we're coming right up on that
line when we're George we're we're
pulling up on you when's the next book
Eight Episodes in seven episodes or was
it seven episodes and six I think it was
eight and seven right something like
that yeah and the butcher just went oh
and open up yeah so there's an element
when you're basing uh when you're basing
a show on an IP like that where you're
dealing with a pre-existing thing that's
it that isn't done yet that's a whole
different set of circumstances you got
to work under but that is another fine
example of you know like some of the
conditions that we're dealing with
because one of the most popular things
to do in Hollywood is adapt a proven
book or book series to the screen I
thought that I was I was so happy to see
his his dark materials get a mini series
or you know three seasons that were
actually like you know in accordance
with the books because let me tell you I
saw the movie and I was like
that that's when I realized that you
can't do justice to uh to a novel in
most cases you know or like an ongoing
series like that with just a two-hour
movie there's just not enough real
estate there you can't Lord of the Rings
I think the just the
for lack of a better book adaptation
that comes to mind I mean there's
obviously great ones I love JoJo rabbit
but that's not truly a book adaptation
and you know there's a half a dozen
other things that can come up to mind
but Lord of the Rings shows that like
hey if you want to truly adapt something
right take your time and for True
Tolkien Tolkien people like the movies
really aren't all that like because they
drop some stuff out I still love them to
death and I'm not like poking nerd nerd
but God I thought I thought Peter
Jackson nailed it and as much as allowed
me some Guillermo del Toro I did not uh
I didn't like what he did with The
Hobbit because The Hobbit is my all-time
favorite book well well Guillermo del
Toro left the hobby that was PJ again oh
that's right you're right yeah if we
would have had GMO on there
yeah that's the thing about stretching
out there's The Hobbit book is that
thick Lord of the Rings not thick but
they still got six hours but I think
that's a good that's a good allegory for
what we're talking about with the 10 to
like the 16 18 20 episode Seasons if
you're following a narrative that's
already been made
fit it to where you need it to fit 8 10
12 episodes yeah perfect stretching that
stuff out you dilute it same thing with
not having material and and just or you
or you don't give it enough room to
breathe and therefore don't do it just
to see it yeah yeah the material should
dictate how long that this thing is
rather than Executives going I want
three films and the credit is going oh
we've got material for two
um and but I think there's a there's a
definite skill about taking a book and
turn it into a movie or because if
you're too
um if you try to follow the book too
much a lot of books don't they tend to
have the finale and then they they have
you know that that tail off and they
explain things and everybody goes home
and everyone's that's how books are
generally formatted movies don't really
work as well so I think there is a skill
to watch you put in what do you answer
because it's a different medium you know
movies are different to books I know
it's going to shock a lot of people in
the audience but they're different and I
think there's definitely a skill to how
do you adapt a book and then but then
people will get annoyed it's either
that's too strict and they follow the
book too much and it's boring or
whatever or are you varied and you
wandered off the book and you thought
it's because it's different it's yeah I
agree and and yeah I think that there's
there's things you can do justice in
certain mediums and there are things
that you can't you know I I just I I
don't appreciate blatant money grabs
like splitting up uh you know The Hobbit
and uh
yeah like the way they did you know like
two I can understand too but three just
yes come on
yeah I have thoughts I have thoughts
three hour movie not two two in our
family movies well and then and we'll
split it up and do two releases but then
still pay everybody as if it was one
film
yes because they filmed it back to yeah
but yeah pay it as if it was one film
but release it in two so you get double
the box office yeah yeah yeah
um Shady Hollywood accounting anyway I'm
not just background yeah two DVD sales
two Blu-ray sales two yep two downloads
two digital downloads everything yeah
it's just switching it all the way down
to the bank you know and uh
anyway
and then gives the TV series it is
apparently going to be the same well the
Lord of the Rings is all getting a TV
series that is still in universe and not
a remake it's not gonna be a remake yeah
I'm not gonna work okay
we'll see yeah all the new new line
stuff's gonna be interesting but Laura I
I think Game of Thrones is the perfect
example of that where you can give a
dozen characters two dozen characters
decent to Great character development in
10 episodes still if the material calls
for that if if it's not and you're
coming up with it as you're going
it might be a little bit harder to do
that you might be able to do that in
later Seasons but you have to give time
to breathe I guess earlier on for some
of those new things which helps with
longer episodes and things like that so
so yes and no but if it comes from
material already written
it's doable very doable uh you said
earlier Greg just the way you'd like to
do a dungeon of dragons uh Anthology
series
that's you you explained exactly how I
want them to do Mass Effect if they ever
bring oh yeah nice
they just you can't adapt those games
for two and a half three hours you just
can't build up the world and then bring
in your little MCU tent pole film boom
boom boom yeah do that thing do it again
boom Another Movie do it again boom
Another Movie something like that but
while you were talking about all that
have you heard uh of Joe of course you
know Joe manganello and stuff
that book
oh yeah yep yep
yeah so I think um
I'm not much of a dragon Lance guy
um you know I can I I know that it it's
it appeals to a very you know it it
appeals to a select group of uh fantasy
genre Geeks and that's awesome you know
I'm I'm much more of a
um
Forgotten Realms guy because that's kind
of like the default world right now I
think that uh you know it that that's
that's very tolkien-esque
um I feel like that that would be the
easiest way to relate in but uh you know
when if you want to do dragon Lance and
you got everybody's riding a [__]
dragon and you got all these big dragons
and you got Dragon fights and you got
all this and you feel like dragons with
the dragons inside the dragons and
Dragons is where it's at so cool you
know but what I would really love to say
is that sounds fun yeah but the one that
I really really want to see
Dark Sun okay if you don't know this
this is like d d does Mad Max okay
what yeah yeah I'm not familiar with any
of these books all I know is Dragon
Lance is like one of the more popular
ones and that's the one that manginella
wants to make but yeah and do more power
to him dude and you know what if if
someone's got the stroke to get that
done he might be one of them so I think
that I know that he's he's pitching a
series right now I know there's somebody
else at pitching a series right now uh
and and that's the thing is that there
are folks who are like yes let's do
let's do the the ongoing series what I'm
hoping is that they don't make the
mistake of just limiting it to one set
of characters in one story if you did
the you you there's enough different
campaign settings and there's enough
different uh opportunities for
storytelling and the the world is all
fascinating enough that we could see
d d done in an American Horror Story
fashion where it's in every season's a
new story and you bring back some of the
cast as new characters you bring in new
actors and everything else like I feel
like that that's
for for something that is as sprawling
and as open concept as Dungeons and
Dragons is I feel like that's the way to
do it
um and then you know I and we even see
this right now with all the the Star
Wars shows on Disney plus all the Star
Wars shows are leading up to the big
crossover event that's going to be the
movie you know and it's like that's what
you do
that's what you [__] do you do the um
you do you you you establish the
characters and you figure out who the
fan favorites are then you write a
[__] movie around the fan favorites
and as they're tying up something that's
been like the Common Thread between each
of the things and Kaboom there's your
money there's your formula hire me to
run your [__] show guys come on let's
go they might need you I'm down I'm down
I'm the nerd that can get this [__] done
like I'm I'm hereby throwing my hat in
the ring for consideration here and I'll
be your backup I love because I just
know anything Star Wars uh just just
characters anything I I love that stuff
I I really want them to do well with it
do you have hope for Ahsoka
I'm um here's the thing I deliberately
don't watch trailers and things for for
like upcoming series and things that I'm
interested in I don't like having those
spoilers I know that thrawn's gonna be
in there like I mean that's obvious
because that was revealed in Boba Fett
you know like so I know a couple of
things I know about some of the
Crossovers between
um the Clone Wars and Rebels and the
animated series and things like that
we're gonna see some of the live-action
characters or some of them in live
action just like we did at the end of
Mandalorian like I know that there's
going to be certain things that happen
but largely I'm trying to stay ignorant
because I still like having that child
like Wonder of holy [__] like my wife
has pictures of me when I saw uh you
know like she she actually got a photo
of me and my jaw hitting the floor when
uh when when Luke Skywalker showed up I
think I could say that safely now right
people are still pissed off at season
three over even think about season two
nowadays yeah so but what you know like
like I I like I like uh being amazed and
I like being surprised so I try to avoid
trailers and I try to like keep away
from stuff and uh you know I want I I in
this in this case though I did see the
trailer for The Next Step next season of
lower decks which I'm super excited for
but I don't feel like that in certain in
certain things it's okay because it's
like okay well this is silly I'm not
heavily invested but my Star Wars I
don't I don't want to know what's coming
because I want to be like blown away so
you know yeah well I'm sorry sorry guys
I've got to run next I've got a previous
engagement so I'm not sure you're
talking musicals aren't you I'm we are
going to be talking Star Trek but um
he's going to be waiting for me so I
I've already been absolutely amazing
speak to you I would love to catch you
again in geek count on Star Trek at some
point absolutely man I would love that I
would absolutely love that jacket well
we will get together through Harris and
uh saw that because that would be
amazing but um I don't know how this is
going to work because I think we're
gonna have two live streams at the same
time on Sidetrack very shortly so let's
see if that breaks the internet
um Harris I'll try not to actually end
the stream like I did last time
oh wait okay so everybody here real
quick
I'm gonna I'm removing Sidetrack from
streaming over here don't don't stress
it I think we can go live twice it's
fine
the the musical whichever your field M
cubed And subscribe and you can watch
the Star Trek episode late all right you
heard it from the horse
not the horse's mouth the Gophers sorry
Mia Fox Jamie a gopher Matt our other
British guy on Sidetrack a badger and
then stormy our resident rocket
scientist who lives in New Mexico uh
what was stormy oh the wise old owl we
also call him Danny Gandalf because he
looks like Gandalf and Danny DeVito put
together so
yeah yeah we can't I gotta run guys so
so much thank you so much really cool
I'll speak to you soon thank you so much
man